three two one
hello and welcome to active inference
lab live stream number 27.0
it's august 23 2021 and we're going to
be discussing the paper active inference
applicability to different types of
social organization explained through
reference to industrial engineering and
quality management
so welcome to the active inference lab
we are a participatory online lab that
is communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at the links here on this slide
this is a recorded and archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for lifestreams
at the short link you can find the
roadmap of the upcoming discussions that
we're going to be having and these are
going to be group discussions on august
24th tomorrow and then august 31st for
number 27.1 and 2
and hopefully the author will be joining
us for both discussions and we have some
openings in the coming weeks if you want
to
join for a session or if you want to
recommend somebody who should join
today in active stream 27.0 we're going
to be learning and discussing about this
paper with the aforementioned long title
by stephen fox and the link is here
and just like a lot of
um the other zero videos all of them
this video is just an introduction for
some of the ideas it's not a review or a
final word it's kind of always this
assemblage of
all of the participants here just
modifying the slides and going down a
few avenues that we thought were
interesting and
setting up some questions to discuss in
the dot one and dot two
so we'll go over the aims and the claims
of the paper and the abstract and
roadmap and then talk about keywords
then go through the figures and tables
so if you want to participate in these
group discussions tomorrow or
the following week then just let us know
or save and submit your questions
and get in touch with us if you want to
participate
so we can just start with
hello and then it will be cool to hear
from both of you what
drew you to the paper or what made you
interested in talking about it
i'm daniel and i'm in california
so whoever wants to go first
i'm blue and i'm a independent research
consultant in new mexico and um i liked
this paper it was a really like
refreshing kind of interesting um and
very readable perspective compared to a
lot of the other papers and um it made
some links with
industrial engineering which i thought
was
were interesting and um kind of like a a
new take on active inference and fep
dean i'm i'm up here in calgary and
what i found interesting about the paper
is just looking at it through the lens
of
engineering's uh
engineering's
priors i guess in terms of
what they would hold up as active
inference just because of what they do
every single day
um and again
that kind of juxtaposed with the social
piece was really interesting to me
because
not to over generalize but when you're
focusing on how to break something down
you don't tend to tend to look at the
holes so i thought that was really
interesting uh to try to pull those two
things together and make them coherent
i agree there's that discussion of the
interfaces between the engineered system
and
the actual way it's used in the niche
which i think we're going to return to
when we're talking about like a
bookshelf
so the paper is
the title the link are shown here
and uh
i guess uh maybe
do either if you want to just read the
first uh two aims and claims
sure
so the principal contribution of this
paper is to relate active inference
theory to everyday practice in social
organization
active inference is a cult
corollary of the free energy principle
which formalizes cognition in the
autopolitic organization of living
systems that resist the second law of
thermodynamics by occupying a limit
limited repertoire of states thus
persisting as bounded self-organizing
systems over time
okay and then i'll read the
last two then anyone can give a thought
it is explained throughout the paper how
industrial engineering and quality
management better enable social
organization to occupy a limited number
of states in order to persist as a
bounded self-organizing systems over
time rather than dissipating into their
surrounding environment
although previous papers by others have
encompassed active inference up to the
levels of sociocultural cognition this
is the first paper to address active
inference in everyday organizational
practice including industrial
engineering and quality management
so the paper is setting up to be just
like one more plank towards applying
active inference bridging some of the
practices that are already in use in
the fields that we're going to be
exploring like the quality management
and industrial engineering and then sort
of the adjacent possible for what kinds
of systems could exist in those domains
so
sometimes we have a more mathematical
paper or more
philosophical paper this one's going to
use a lot more of the jargon
and like dean said the priors of
engineering so that's why it's kind of
cool to hear about it
daniel can i add something to that yep
yeah i just think it's interesting that
i think we
to use a bridging metaphor is seems just
to be a really easy thing to do
and then i think what what the paper
in terms of the aims and the claims does
is tries to point out where that
that connection might exist
and we can always argue whether or not
it exists in all
situations at all times but i i do think
that there are some times again when
we can hold a static
connection between
an idea of one scale and an idea at
another scale and so
not all scales
allow for that or have those affordances
but sometimes they do so i mean that
part of it
maybe what we need to do is separate the
times when
the metaphor works and when it doesn't
agree being utilitarian implies some
sort of utility metric
having a preference for reward or for
preferred states implies those being
defined maybe and also i think this will
come up
in this paper
because it's all about which are the
useful metrics to check up on useful
policies to pursue
okay
so
does anyone want to read abstract one
i'll read it
active inference is a physics of life
process theory of perception action and
learning that's applicable to natural
and artificial agents in the paper
active inference theories related to
different types of practice
in social organization here the term
social organization
is used to clarify that this paper does
not encompass organization in biological
systems
rather the paper addresses active
inference and social organization that
utilizes industrial engineering
quality management and artificial
intelligence alongside human
intelligence
social organization referred to in this
paper
can be in private companies public
institutions other for-profit or
not-for-profit organizations and any
combination of them the relevance of
active inference theory is explained in
terms of variation free energy
prediction errors
generative models
and markup blankets
pretty interesting i think usually when
we talk about these multi-scale
perspectives on institutions cities
societies
it's always like
the entire edifice all of the niche and
everything that's moving in it is part
of this one biological organism
and
or at least biological co-regulating
system and here it's very explicit that
it's trimming the biological component
from the engineered component it's kind
of like the car and then the passenger
so then instead of just saying well the
car and the passengers are part of the
same extended cognitive niche because
that's one way to look at that situation
like it's a extended affordance that the
driver has
another way to think of it is by making
a very clean partitioning
recognizing that there's still this
immersion function like cars don't drive
themselves but you can still parse out
the individual who's using the car from
the design process of making the car
and one one thing that's added to that
if you haven't read
lucy and i'll always kill her last name
lucy suckman s-u-c-h-m-a
she's got a book out many years ago that
i think has still got some
incredible shelf life it's called um
it's reconfiguring the human machine
interface
and if you haven't read it it's a
fantastic book in terms of
looking at how
her case study is how people
walk up to a photocopying machine for
the first time where the engineers
are trying to make it intuitive and how
the human interface with that isn't
always necessarily something that you
can
engineer for
so something to consider if you're
looking at this
this
if i could just give another thought i
think that um the uncoupling of social
organization from biological
organization is kind of a really like
unique and fresh perspective
compared to some of the other papers
that we've looked at i mean especially
considering that like
i mean it is biological organization
because it's happening in in biological
creatures but it's it's an interesting
like partition that the author creates
to um
make it
known that it's not talking about
hierarchical
organization in structures or societies
yep so we don't need to worry about
what's inside of the tissues and go into
the biological
organization okay i'll read the second
abstract and then anyone can give a
thought
active inference theory is most relevant
to the social organization of work that
is highly repetitive
by contrast there are more challenges
involved in applying active inference
theory for social organization of less
repetitive endeavors such as
one-of-a-kind projects
these challenges need to be addressed in
order for active inference to provide a
unifying framework for different types
of social organization employing human
and artificial intelligence
so i have a thought on that
it might be somewhat controversial but
um
you know
so
i think that um the highly repetitive so
i mean i think about active inference in
terms of exploration and exploitation
and i think like it really depends on on
where your generative model rests right
so like is the generative model like the
model of the organization or is it the
model of the individual because i i
think that um doing a highly repetitive
project that reminds me of exploitation
where like a one-off project can be like
exploration like so so you can still
like update your model depending on on
exploring some new avenue by this little
side project but like you come back to
updating your model the model of your
business yourself the way that you work
your organization
with knowledge about about how to do
processes in a one-off kind of process
i agree
especially because we talk about it a
lot in the context of generating
strategic novelties perhaps
and those are seemingly less repetitive
um but
i think there's gonna be um some further
clarification on that
and also this points to this uh yeah
exciting areas like one shot learning or
like true structural novelty and active
inference models that's something that
we've talked about in other areas like
how do you know when to be tweaking the
knobs of the parameters as you currently
have them set up versus expand a hidden
state into two types of hidden state or
something like that
again thinking about what the system is
realistically or from this
instrumentalist way okay
the roadmap
is written out here
and it's a
we're gonna go through it in rough order
it introduces in each of these sections
one of the kind of key ideas or
principles the variational free energy
prediction errors generative models
markov blankets
and survival
and then in section seven active
inference is proposed as a unifying
framework so this is kind of one of
those classic paper layouts with some
disciplinary sections one through n
disciplinary sections
and then
uh the next section is active inference
as a unifying framework and then the
next section is like challenges or
current research directions and then a
concluding section maybe with a more um
call to action or more philosophical
uh liftoff
there were a bunch of keywords and i
think we're going to get to all of them
um so two columns of keywords
uh let me shrink the video
two columns secured okay
so
first
active inference
uh it's in the title of the paper and
here's how it's written in the paper who
wants to read the large text here
i got it
uh active inference is the physics of
life process theory of perception action
and learning
active inference generates predictions
active inference predictions are based
on knowledge learned from past
situations and perceptions of present
situations active inference minimizes
errors between actions that are planned
through the inference of predictions and
what happens when the planned actions
are taken
so this is the first lines of the paper
right in the introduction that's how it
begins with no
active inference is the first word so
that's sort of the opening shot and
it's just a cool
framing
to bring it out as a physics of life
process theory
yet this isn't about biological
organization so it's almost like
recognizing the origins
and some of the motivations for the kind
of modeling that active inference
provides
yet making another later decision to
partition the system of interest a
certain way so cool framing and then the
uh next
lines so kind of shrinking that
definition of active inference
um
this is because prediction errors
cause unwanted surprise
surprises which individually or
accumulatively can threaten survival by
going beyond the limited number of
states in which survival is possible by
contrast minimizing prediction errors
facilitates survival through least
action
so this is also linking up several of
those key terms that are going to be
section headers later but it's just this
idea that um
predictions about the external world
especially if they incorporate
preferences that are optimistic
help reduce the complexity of deciding
which actions to take and then the way
that that gets operationalized is with
the process theory of prediction error
minimization which is
a real-time estimate of how good the
generative model is performing
and then just
add anything or
say more here but
it's just an interesting
topic how it's described as the
principle of survival through least
action
so
what is this principle of least action
and
how do we reconcile
active biological agents
as being in one way participating under
this survival through least action even
if it's just a misnomer what does that
really mean
and then how does survival through least
action
contrast or overlap with
more familiar phrasing probably survival
of the fittest like
is the survival of the fittest the
survival of the least
active or how should we read this
relationship between
uh maybe darwinian conceptions of
fitness and which individuals survive
versus this physics based
framing of survival through at least
action under the
principles of least action
stationary action principle that's
something daniel yeah
yeah so i think it's interesting that
you
depending on how you define each of
these terms
that you can you can sort of
transfer or oscillate across frame what
a frame is which to me is
identifying a focal point maybe a margin
or a limit and what if it is what goes
inside the other like
glove and hand or hand and glove and i
think sometimes we talk about
a niche fit
but that's that's different than a what
the frame of the niche is
so the fact that we're we're sort of
ping-ponging back and forth
between the two i just wonder whether or
not
we're looking at the same thing or if we
realize we're looking at two things at
once
nice
continuing on with the introduction
it's written
active inference is a corollary of the
free energy principle fep which
formalizes cognition of the autopoetic
organization of living systems
within fep active systems must occupy a
limited repertoire of states this
requires minimizing the long-term
average of surprise associated with
sensory exchanges with the world
minimizing surprise enables them to
resist a natural tendency toward
two disorder
so
this just kind of relates to some
questions like
how do framings for this sort of active
intelligent behavior
what other framings exist
and how do we think about
broad concepts like reward preference
and curiosity and surprise in active
inference
um and then the last paragraph then any
thoughts or not surprise rests on
predictions about sensations
which depend on an internal generative
model of the world
in particular although surprise cannot
be measured directly a free energy bound
on surprise can be suggesting that
agents minimize free energy by changing
their predictions about what sensory
inputs will come from actions or by
changing the predicted sensory inputs
through changing action
this just reminds me of the kind of
fundamental uh
pairing in active inference where the
ways that you can go down that free
energy gradient are either by updating
parameters of your internal model
learning development or
by updating action states
which is through action because you
can't control external states directly
and you can't control the incoming
sensory data directly
then all you can do is control those two
states that are under your control the
internal states and action states
all right another term was the markov
blanket
so anyone want to just like
give what what's what's the markov uh
101 or what's
what's the way in which mark-up blankets
came into play in this paper or in
another context
so
um marco blankets are essentially the
the boundary or or how how a system
creates a boundary and how you can
define essentially like a
non-equilibrium steady state system with
a martal blanket um i thought it was an
interesting
um play in this paper and i think maybe
we'll unpack it here in later on in the
in the intro video
we just in number 26 talked a bunch
about markov blankets so suffice to say
that there's um
it's still open exactly which cases
which sense of the markov blanket is
meant on this continuum from analytical
and mathematical with markov og blanket
the bayesian statistical generalization
by pearl and others and then this
partitioning into incoming sensory and
outgoing active states of the blanket by
fristen and others and then how that
exactly relates to all these other
topics that we're
discussing
okay i'll play the video at um 46
seconds blue what was exciting to you
about this
uh so this is the video um from the
tesla ai day that just happened last
week and this is um
it's a humanoid um
robot that uh tesla is going to attempt
to design
um and so i just pulled this definition
of artificial intelligence from um
like google and it said the theory and
development of computer systems able to
perform tasks that normally require
human intelligence such as visual
perception speech recognition decision
making and translation between languages
and and so spoiler alert uh this is
actually not uh not a robot this is
actually like a person um but but he
made it you know look like a robot that
was getting up and then like bam i'm
gonna dance but i think like that kind
of movement and perception about about
space that kind of spatial awareness is
something that's still
very much a challenge for um ai so so
that's why i threw this video in there
agreed will be interesting to see how
they do
processing and what kinds of algorithms
and hardware and software end up being
used for real-time robotics systems
any comments on
artificial intelligence or or
anything dean
again i
don't spend a whole lot of time on this
because to me artificial intelligence is
always a it's always a post-hoc domain
even this example um
can we create a copy of this
so i mean it's already been done by
something and now we're trying to
re-engineer it or
re-develop it as opposed to what active
inference is which is
the inclusion of ad-hoc the what if so
i mean if they can get artificial
intelligence to a place that it's
it's including what if in that in the
truest sense of all possibilities then
i'll probably
be quite excited or scared i'm not sure
which
nice
so
some other keywords were social and
organization
and one of the
goal statements of the paper was
this paper is intended to contribute to
bridging the gap between theoretical
papers in active inference theory which
have been reported to be too opaque to
be understood widely
and potential application opportunities
in the multi-intelligence social
organization
that being social organization that
employs human intelligence and different
types of artificial intelligence
so
and whoever put this image what did it
mean or represent in the context of the
paper
so i i just looked so i didn't
i don't know that it's necessarily
really in the context of the paper but i
i started to look into like how are
societies organized right and so this is
like i just was doing some googling and
i thought that this was an interesting
um paper and the title and the author
there in the small print if you're able
to read them but
this uh is like a um a state
organization right and and it's you know
describes the fascist media model model
as focusing on community and culture
and it describes the communist uh media
model as focusing on state bureaucracy
and the liberal media model as focusing
on market exchange which i just i just
thought was interesting and just kind of
an interesting way to um
to
i don't know reflect on societal
organization and what what is the
central
theme there
and it's uh kind of in line with that
partitioning of the kind of the car from
the user because not included here are
like the human users this is kind of
everything but the eyes on the tv this
is just partitioning the the structure
of the organization as an engineered
object
so that's a cool um
similarity
yeah
so we just had a guest stream and and
pranav and raphael
even they were debating
can we can we say that something that's
an emergent property in an individual
which is then something that we can test
as an emerging property within a dyad
can also become an emerging property
within these high variability states and
even they couldn't agree
that there's there's some sort of a
a parallel
i think we know that on these high
variability states like a social
organization
afterwards again we can
we can take an account of what it became
but we it's really hard to know
where it's going even if you break it
down into a
communist or or a fascist
direction it's telling us like you say
what what direction the high down the
highway the car is going but that but
beyond that it's still a lot of guessing
yep
so i guess that's where industrial
engineering comes into play for that
designing for that car on the highway
industrial engineering involves applying
methods such as task analysis and job
design
in order to predict results evaluate
results and improve results from
processes during their development
the application of industrial
engineering has been progressing around
the world since the 1900s
so
wasn't an area i was too familiar with i
saw a lot of mention of the 99 out of
100 and the three standard deviations
and then halt the process
so that kind of just was an interesting
uh thing to hear about
any thoughts or we can continue on
okay as i guess a related field of
industrial engineering is quality
management
and so this is a type of system
that involves i guess hardware and
software and behavioral protocols
quality management systems qms involve
documenting processes which have been
developed through industrial engineering
as process specifications work
procedures etc
monitoring processes for conformance to
specifications etc and using
observations of non-conformances to
inform the further development of
processes both industrial engineering
and qms are focused on the continuous
improvement of processes the application
of industrial engineering has been
progressing around the world since the
1900s in quality management since the
1950s
any thoughts on that
just having been a business owner it's
uh you know it's it's a process
yep definitely makes me think about uh
precision of measurement changing and
then
what can be measured and what can be
measured gets entrapped and then what
can be regulated becomes gamed and all
these sort of complex ways that
assessment of performance
fits one into local versus
global optima
you can also see how instructionalism
got systematized
yep if there's a way to do it and this
is the way that's approved
um even if the later becomes like a you
know an improvement in the protocol or
some sort of uh change in the context
maybe it can't be utilized because it's
not part of the approved version
and so
there's no simple answer there because
you can't just say well okay accept all
changes and then if you just say okay
we'll have a small bar for making edits
it's like there's no perfect trade-off
point with the false positives and the
false negatives
especially for situations that truly are
ambiguous
which is why we fall back to these
approaches that put us at
the kind of functional inflection point
of the pragmatic and epistemic outcomes
which is like active inference rather
than just pursuing reward
over short term or over some other time
frame
but common to all these different
frameworks for control theory is
basically statistical process control
so
maybe whoever made this slide was it
yeah blue go for it
so statistical process control is a
collection of tools and techniques used
to measure and analyze process data in
order to characterize the behavior of
our processes and achieve process
control
and so in the paper i don't know how
much
we'll get into it here but the paper
really describes statistical process
control and gives a figure similar to
this so you have normal process
variation which they described as six
sigma uh deviation from whatever is
optimal so there's the optimal which is
like the green line and then three sigma
to the up and three sigmas to the down
as to like an over or under estimate or
of your you know target
and then anytime that you have a process
that deviates from the six sigma range
you um have this special cause variation
and and so like in like
the business
schema that i'm familiar with at least
which is minimal but some um you know
you have you do this root cause analysis
like why is there this special cause
variation like what is what happened in
that um in that one circumstance we have
to go and analyze that instance to find
out why it was outside of the sigma
deviation because it's just like that's
an unacceptable data point at that point
nice good explanation
how about thermodynamic entropy
uh also um
this was also me but um it's a quantity
representing the unavailability of a
system's thermal energy for conversion
into mechanical work often interpreted
as the degree of disorder or randomness
in the system
and so you know there's the law of
thermodynamics that says that entropy in
the universe is always increasing so
um becoming going from
more ordered to less ordered or so from
highly ordered to more disordered which
this kind of shows in this example uh
things spreading apart and like it's
like you would if you left town for two
years and you came back and found that
your house was a mess that wouldn't
really be surprising like even if you
left it clean even if you know i mean
just things deteriorate and fall apart
and dust goes in and whatever rodents
creep around and stuff like that
and it's that apparent
and empirical local organization of
matter like into bones and flesh and
life and whatnot
and also the always and only
co-occurrence of that kind of local
organization of energy with cybernetic
or anticipatory behavior
that's what motivates a kind of
framework that is going to on one hand
work for particles but also work for
active particles and all of the
continuum between so that's why there's
all these different cognitive structures
as well as physical structures that are
being linked together through basically
physics
and by hooking to free energy principle
and variational methods and all these
other areas of math and physics then it
puts active inference just like one step
closer towards embodiment on some of
those different
pathways
okay
information theoretic entropy
uh so this is the the shannon entropy as
it's often referred to because it was i
think first described by claude shannon
um but i always put uh maxwell's demon
here when i'm thinking about relating
thermodynamic energy and informational
entropy and i think was it alex kiefer
wrote a paper that really
we did in one of the live streams that
really kind of outlined how these are
connected with the helmholtz
distribution and so if you really want
to dig deeper into these relationships
um that's a good way to do it but i
always think about you know so maxwell's
demon is is the idea that you know if
you have molecules like shown on the
left here in you know this box and you
have two sides of the box and there's a
partition
in the center and like the you know
they're cold and hot molecules
so if you knew which molecule was hot
and which molecule was cold so the demon
is sitting there who can see is the
molecule hot or cold and only lets the
hot ones go through to the right and
only lets the cold ones go through to
the left and every time he opens the
partition
effectively that is is work
and so just kind of conceptually um
that like shows that that the
relationship between information and
work the more information you have
the less work you have to do maybe so
that's kind of the relationship that i
think about in my mind
and then there's a formal definition of
shannon entropy um down below but it's
usually
given in informational context as a
measure of surprise as we've talked
about on the live stream many times and
they relate information as negative
entropy so it's the the reverse
surprises the reverse of uh surprise or
sorry information is the reverse of
surprise
cool thanks for the explanation dean any
thoughts on that
yeah one of the things i i mean i love
this thanks blue because thank you for
that explanation it's really it's really
good so one of the people i'm reading
right now is a
guy by the name of dan siegel and his
book about the mind and what he talks
about is
um when people are at dis ease so not in
an easy state but when they're when
they're struggling with something he
talks about the fact that there's one of
two ends of a continuum be it blue and
red
in this example one one end is chaos and
the other is
rigidity
and so from an information theoretic
entropy state are we stuck are we bored
are we feeling trapped or are we being
overwhelmed or underwhelmed
meaning we're we're
we're not in that in between state and
so i think that
i think there's a lot there's a lot that
can be done if we get a basic understand
understanding of maxwell's demon without
sort of getting
scared off by it
cool it's almost like um yeah what would
these particles and their temperature
represent if they were i don't know
ideas or something more related to
inference rather than just particles
because we're always looking at that
intersection between the physical
systems and the informational systems
all right
variational free energy
so this keyword was defined in the paper
as the difference between predicted
sensory inputs and actual sensory inputs
when monitoring processes
um
vfe increases as the difference
increases between what is predicted to
happen if actions are taken and what
does not hap what does happen when those
actions are taken the more prediction
errors there are the more thermodynamic
energy will be consumed amidst the
thermodynamic entropy of remedial
actions corrective actions restorative
actions and firefighting this will leave
less thermodynamic energy available for
doing productive work comprising
productive actions
thus if the variational free energy is
high then thermodynamic entropy eg
energy not available for doing
productive work will be high and the
thermodynamic free energy
eg energy available for doing productive
work will be low
hence variational free energy can have
an inverse relationship
to thermodynamic free energy
this is because the bigger a prediction
error which can be considered in terms
of bigger vfe the smaller can be the
thermodynamic free energy available to
do productive work so this is a pretty
interesting
passage did either of you have a thought
on it
um
it's exploring this thermo thermo info
nexus in a little bit of a different way
and
on one hand it's kind of confusing that
the variational free energy
is going to be the opposite of the
thermodynamic free energy but it's
almost like
what is happening here and um it just
to see that they have a negative
relationship it's like if the engine
were perfectly anticipatory and super
efficient it would be carrying out a ton
of work if it's moving in a super
spurious heat producing way
then the product a lot of variational
free energy a lot of surprising
observations
relative to functional uh operation of
the motor then your capacity to perform
work
to capture those very noisy vibrations
is low and so a lot of the
underlying
uh potential becomes dissipated rather
than used to perform kind of useful
inference useful action so not sure if
that's a correct
mapping but i think it'll be cool to
talk to the author because this is a
very fascinating idea about how
different
formalizations of free energy um
actually relate to modeling processes
yeah blue
so it's like i i really thought this was
kind of what made me think of maxwell's
demon right so
it was interesting because you know the
variational free energy when we talk
about minimizing free energy we always
think about like as minimizing surprise
right so if we if we minimize surprise
then then we don't have to do all this
thermodynamic energy like the
firefighting that they talked about and
i think that the paper when we get into
the five wise and that figure i think
we'll elaborate a little bit more on
that but um
the
it's just interesting because we don't
have to output as much work and that's
kind of what made me think about about
maxwell's demon and kind of why i snuck
that in there um but yeah you're right i
don't know like you know i think that
the relationship between
um
info dynamics and thermodynamics is
still very much being defined there's a
lot of very recent research um that's
looking closely at how those two uh
relate to one another
nice dean
yeah i just
i immediately
said to myself
i really want my autonomic nervous
system to work and i don't want to have
to think about it because
a lot of the mechanical things
are dependent on that so
i'm not
i'm not sort of pulling apart what the
claim is here
but i think
if you read that you're kind of saying
okay
um
[Music]
a lot of the surprise you're not even
aware of because you're on an autonomic
nervous system is functioning correctly
great
point there it's almost like a surprise
variational surprise does not equate to
attention or even especially the
conscious awareness of
attention in a human
psychological situation
so it's totally possible that like the
difference in pressure sensing depending
on your body's posture that's
completely normalized out that's
recalibrated for the expectations of
body position
without coming to our attention unless
we bring it to our attention so that and
many other similar examples
so dean i love how you're like not able
to to stay outside of the biological
partition
right
well i i just i'm not again i'm not
i want to be able to create with this
stuff
i mentioned that and so
to me
to willfully ignore that is hard for me
to do i'm not saying it's not possible
i'm not saying it's it's the right thing
to do here i'm just struggling to let go
of it i want to let go of it but i'm
having a hard time with it well and i
think for all of us you know the urge to
apply
to every system is very strong
right here's table one so here's the
mapping
of a bunch of different sets of terms
from active inference constructs
and then thinking about how they're
applied in industrial engineering and
quality management practice so
variational free energy which we just
we're talking about
is the difference between the predicted
sensory inputs and actual sensory inputs
the variational free energy upper bound
as well as its lower bound is basically
the range in which that system is
working well it's like the loaves of
bread are within the calibration range
and we can just keep on pumping them out
precision waiting
has to do with which aspects of the
process are monitored with which what
level of precision
for example which width of a part has to
be machined in fractions of a millimeter
versus other tolerances
and then the expected free energy is the
expected energy
between the preferred sensory inputs
from process operation
and the actual sensory inputs
so the variational free energy is the
difference between the prediction and
the actual so you have some generative
model of your data center and then you
have the generative model of the
temperature through time
and then the comparison with the actual
but here it's about the preferred
versus the actual
so that's like we we we recognize that
it is warmer than we would like it to be
which is why we're conditioning our
policy in the long range towards getting
back to that zone but for now we need to
also have an accurate sensor measurement
so that's also a nice juxtaposition
that's not always finessed in other
papers
the next and all these keywords the
first set were about free energy and
precision and how these terms are
calculated relative to one another
the second set of terms in table one
is some of the
key terms of bayesian statistics
so just to read only the constructs um
and these are also really helpful
because
we're as a lab thinking about what are
the core terms of active inference what
are the definitions that are general
enough to be
really
educational but also not too limiting or
prioritize one sense over another for
example so the bayesian terms that would
be found in any other course or textbook
on bayesian statistics
prior expected posterior actual
posterior preferred posterior and
prediction error
so that kind of puts the predictive
processing as a
under the umbrella of bayesian
statistics
okay
the next set of terms in the table
was related to this dichotomy of two
different types of inference so
epistemic inference was defined as
updating the definitions of process
during process improvement based upon
analysis of non-conformance reports
whereas instrumental inference is
updating which actions will be included
in the process during process
improvement
so this is sort of like epistemic
knowledge based this is about updating
the knowledge
based upon especially the times where
things don't go right
and then this is like
policy inference action planning as
inference because it's like
instrumentally is actually like about
what the instrument is going to do
so
and then the last
okay any thoughts on these terms
okay then the next set of terms in table
one
was
mark hall blanket
internal state and external state
so definitely check out number 14
number 26 a few of the other live
streams to learn more about the markup
blanket and this is the figure from
uh decosta at all 2021.
the blanket
is here the boundary state between the
internal state
of the social organization
so those are the ones
and the and the external state of the
environment when operating processes are
defined in the quality
management system
then what are those internal states
those are the social or organizational
processes developed during industrial
engineering for minimum risk in the
process environment
and then the external state is the
environment
so
that's kind of mapping the markov
blanket kind of the car
the interfaces and outside the car or
maybe that's not the perfect mapping but
i think that's kind of what is being
suggested
and then the last
few terms of table one
are four of just the general constructs
general principles that are also section
headers and important topics risk
ambiguity principle of least action and
principle of survival
dean
yeah so i think all of this ties in
to a
a way of looking at the world through
through rows and columns which is fine i
mean it's it's a good it's a good place
to try to look at things and analyze
them but
not everybody
not everybody creates off of that
because not everybody
is necessarily looking for a precision
forward view sometimes
you're you're experimenting and you're
making all kinds of mistakes and
learning from that as well and so you
again you just want to just want to see
this for what it is it's it's nothing
wrong with it but it's not
it's not the only way
that's all
blue anything
okay so then
there's the figures
and these will recall some of the key
terms we talked about earlier
uh the text says as shown in figure one
spc charts these statistical process
control charts
have upper and lower control limits
and processes need to remain within
these limits processes that go outside
the limits do not meet specifications
that define intended states so left side
good top of the drake meme right side
bad bottom of the drake meme not working
okay
figure two is this five whys so it's
written out here more textually if you
wanna pause it and look at it and here
it's more graphical so do either if you
wanna
give a thought on the five wise or
okay well the scenario that's laid out
is uh
kind of working backwards
from why there was a not reliable
organization
and the five wise it's actually not
related to aristotle's four y's but that
would have been a nice opportunity maybe
there's a four by five matrix but these
five y's are referring to
um needing to go back kind of five
layers
or like five
derivatives up the chain
asking
what led to a high reliability
organization being unreliable
so the general case of this sort of
cascading failure
in terms of variational free energy so
the general phrasing is that there's
high
uncertainty high entropy in work
instructions so the ikea instructions
are not accessible enough to many people
or the radio is really blurry so people
can't hear what letters are being said
and then that makes the variational free
energy high because of prediction errors
which then leads to unproductive actions
so then you're you're scanning on the
radio because you can't quite lock on
and then that's consuming energy
and then that ends up reducing your
battery so that you can't do what you
actually need to do and then the case in
this truck driver incident
is that the truck driver is getting
ambiguous
logistical data so this itself is a
policy um communication from like you
know some cloud mapping service or the
company that's contracting the trucker
and then this leads to
the driver having increased spatial
uncertainty getting lost
which leads them to drive around
unproductively so they don't have enough
fuel to efficiently complete the
deliveries that are important
and so here's the graphical layout of
the five wise
showing with that example
how on the bottom is the truck drivers
getting the bad
info
and then that surfaces
after sort of several repercussions in
terms of the uh
the um structure of multi-level decision
making
and active inference
how we can
use this framework which maybe is used
in industry
and map it onto the states of decision
making from active inference perspective
but notice that there's no reward here
it's not well drivers
minimize their reward about this or you
know risk on this or maximize their
reward on this so it just shows how this
sort of um framework
has a different framing than people
might expect if the only machine
learning model they were aware of was
machine learning and
specifically reward reinforcement
learning dean
yeah and it isn't just industrial you
can
you can be like me and
jump in the car with two of my friends
who are both
emergency doctors and you're heading off
to the ski hill and at some point the
conversation comes around to there are
no accidents in the world
and of course being emergency doctors
they see the the
outcomes of
of
events
happening to people and so their
perspective is there's always a way of
being able to go back and see
all the
parts of the decision branch and how it
arrived in front of them and them having
to sort of put the pieces back together
again but
again i don't
i don't know that necessarily
that that means that randomness doesn't
come into play and there isn't a
certain part of this where the variation
simply can't be
um
[Music]
calculated in but
i still go skiing with them i don't i
don't
dislike them or defriend them so anyway
yeah
um
it just reminds me of like
when i dropped a hard drive then i
thought well i guess this is the 100
hard drives that fails every year
yes but it was also the one time that i
dropped it so there's always this sort
of like n equals one way to uncouple
uh cause and effect or potentially uh
actionable consequence to the not
reliability of your organization but
then also there's this designing for the
statistics when they decide to make a
recall or not based upon you know the
relative amount of failure
versus
the relative amount of you know legal uh
changes needed something like that so
that's where you talked earlier about
including co-occurrence instead of just
only giving time over to the sequential
aspect of this
yep
so figure 3
frames the quality management systems
the qms the quality manual as a
generative model comprising beliefs
about processes
so it's interesting because it could be
seen as just a cookbook recipe book
instruction book
but it's being
at least deployed in a generative
capacity
and instead of just like saying you know
whip the eggs for five minutes and then
um until they're
frothy or you know until they're this
make peaks it's like we expect it to
make peaks
whip it until your expectation is
achieved
it's a different way to get to that same
outcome now which one is going to be
more resilient if it says five minutes
and there's no peaks then what do you do
do you add something do you keep on
going whereas if you have a precision uh
seeking
process maybe you can be resilient to it
if it only takes two minutes and you
don't overdo it
uh and the the example of something
being correct like 99 out of 100 times
is just used i think just repeatedly in
the paper
just
it could be calibrated differently and
i'm sure it's situational it's just sort
of like shorthand 99 out of 100.
um but yeah
it is defining these qms
in terms of uh the actual active states
so what should be done you know pipette
50 microliters of fluid into the little
tube and then you monitor something
about the process
and then that
leads to this feedback cycle between the
uh the quality management review
and then that
being
in kind of co-evolution
with the industrial engineering itself
and then that leads to the update of the
process in the quality manual in step
four
so that then there's kind of like okay
if it's too low after your first pipette
then do a little bit more pipetting
and then they keep on protecting that 99
um
functional outcome at each of those
nodes that are bifurcating out
okay any thoughts
uh not gonna
read this whole thing but
the top part talks about this design for
assembly and one of the principles is to
make parts either symmetrical or clearly
asymmetrical so nothing in the uncanny
valley this is done so that it is
immediately and unequivocally apparent
how a part is to be put into subassembly
and the this is the famous uh ikea
catalog aesthetic
and how that made uh furniture building
like fun and accessible for some people
i guess
and then in this
second quote
it is kind of thinking about that ikea
paradigm although furniture companies
may not be considering their industrial
engineering in terms of minimizing
variational free energy it is apparent
that its aim is to minimize errors
between what it intends to people to see
when looking at its furniture kits and
what people do see when looking at its
furniture kits
so it's sort of like it's
the goal should be to make it look like
it looks on the sale room floor or like
it looks like in your imagination after
you see the advertising
and then if you can see those flat
pieces of wood and you can see that
instruction booklet and you can see the
policy
then you're going to be not surprised
you're going to be satisfied because
your preference was to have like the
couch there
so just kind of a cool example that
highlights how
our preferences aren't just over
temperature
we often talk about those kinds of
examples but we can also have
preferences for
having affordances or niche
modifications like we can have a
preference to have a handle on something
and then that kind of relates us to this
like behavioral economics under active
inference like what makes somebody
expect there to be a new couch in their
living room and then what makes them
drive out and pick it up on the weekend
and everything
and then
um
it's this kind of idea that the supply
chain is
this extended uncertainty reducer
and it's like bringing stuff to you
and then there's this notion in this
computational industrial case and in the
at home case
where
the assembly information that's provided
is a policy decision from the people who
are making the product and then that
really relates to like participation
in making that product if it's all
pre-compiled then there's no affordance
for participation versus having like a
culture of people working through it
from many different ways so
and then this was just the funny example
of the interface
which said uh
although there may be little risk in
furniture assembly this can be followed
by much ambiguity and furniture
installation so in other words it's not
just about what's on this brochure
because pre-determining all the possible
prediction errors in fixing the
assembled furniture to walls
in millions of different buildings
around the world is very challenging
and so there's this difference between
the assembly information like how do you
just assemble the system of interest
uh which is just the internal and
blanket states of the new uh shelf
what's the difference between that
information how to build the bookshelf
and then the operations like oh well you
didn't tell me that i couldn't kick it
from the side it's like you just told me
how to build it you didn't say that i
couldn't use it this way
and then so how do you
design for internal coherence
versus designing for interoperability
with sort of unknown unknowns and all
these different types of entities that
the system's going to interact with
on the blanket on the interface
so it's not just the ikea
booklet but i thought that was kind of
an interesting notion that even just
building it wasn't really the end of the
story because then people take their
perfectly built bookshelf and then just
like staple it to the wall the wrong way
like ruins both um so dean
yeah and then
and i don't know if you can see this but
then how do you account for this how do
you accomplish somebody who
took a piece of olive wood
any random piece of olive wood and
turned it into something
like this right so it's not there's no
there's no billy there's no way of
deconstructing this you just have to
pick up
you have to pick up something that is a
mark off blanket it's it's it has it's
pre-carved
and then you have to be able to pull out
what you think is in that and how do you
how do you engineer that
well it's it's a completely different
process so
i think i think we're i think as people
were capable of doing both
and i and i just i'd love to talk to the
author
about how how you
how you
do this kind of work when
there's certain results that are
are available and are part of the active
inference model so
it'll be a nice contrast tomorrow yeah
yep nice good point like where's artisan
ship and uh craft in this phrasing
so uh here's an example using that uh
case of the like bookshelf
or the cupboard being bolted to a wall
and this also gets at that partition
between the part of the system that you
can design
and then the part of the system that is
not being considered
so
here the internal states and this is
kind of interesting
it'll be cool to see who is there live
to talk about this sort of embodiment
aspect
the internal state is the person's
embodied prior knowledge of fixing
assembled cupboards to walls and
depending on what they know about you
know carpentry if they're just totally
watching the youtube video and then uh
letting it rip versus if they're
experienced
they're gonna with different materials
they're gonna take actions
and that's going to modify the niche
which is the external state the room to
which the cupboard will be fixed
and that's going to
be reflected in what the person
perceives
and then it's just cool like the
here
maybe there's multiple ways to interpret
the center
it's like there's the wall blocking like
external blocking state then there's
like the affordance block where the
tools are inadequate like you know you
need the hex wrench of size seven and
you only have the size four so you just
can't do it even if you know how to do
it and there's times where even if you
have the right tool it's like it's too
rusty to do it
so there's like it's just a cool
example
and
shows a little bit of that that
horseshoe theory again between
philosophy and engineering where they're
both radically focused on embodiment and
pragmatics
okay
then
the next section after four is seven
active inference as a unifying framework
and so basically they write
an important application of active
inference theory can be as a unifying
framework for a social organization
framework summarized in figure five
which we'll look at in a second
operated through quality management
systems qms via interoperability
protocols at an upper level of
multi-tier enterprise architecture so
before we look at figure five
it's just
like how does active inference serve as
a unifying framework in some of these
areas that we've been talking about for
the last months like
we've heard people use this integrating
word to talk about active in
action and perception engineering
biology
communication cyber physical systems
remote teams etc so just
it's being used a little bit in a
different way here so let's see figure
five and then you can give any thoughts
on it
here organizational active inference
is again being mapped onto this uh sense
internal action external loop this kind
of circular loop the internal states are
the organization's belief just like in
figure four it was the person's embodied
beliefs here it's the organization's
embodied beliefs embodied in the qms
which is again being framed as beliefs
over
uh
processes and states
that
results in human and artificial
intelligence employed to fulfill
specifications procedures etc so these
can be actions that are taken by apis or
bots or by people
this
acts upon the external states
which lead to perceptions of sensory
states which could be the temperature in
the room
it could be the um the ph of the wine it
could be the number of sales on the
course
so then they do industrial engineering
on this loop as an organization
in relationship to integrating
perception and action through internal
state updating pretty much just like
we've been talking about for all these
other active inference systems any
thoughts
okay
table two
uh writes there are many there can be
many reasons why pragmatic subsumes
semantics and leads to prediction errors
for example inept priors and inept
preferred posteriors can come from
lock-ins path dependencies and success
traps which place emphasis on past
experiences over new information
individuals may seek to survive by
learning from filtered information that
supports the preconception of groups
which they believe can support their
individual survival rather than seek
information that supports the efficient
reduction of prediction errors in
external states
so it's almost like
you can't prefer what you prefer so much
otherwise you're gonna um i don't know
maybe follow that local band all the way
to a local end
instead of sometimes
coming out of that local
uh local local attractor
and uh any
want to go for this blue yeah yeah just
it seemed like just confirmation bias
right you seek to survive by learning
the the information that supports the
preconceptions of groups right so that's
like you know i believe this my my can
can my group believe this like i don't
know that's that yeah this is a cool
table it's like okay so in the
perception phase of active inference
you can have a top-down error based upon
inept priors
so you can believe the wrong thing about
what you should expect to see or
you can have the sensor be influenced
interesting about eg emotion but um
that's i guess being phrased as a
bottom-up way that
perception can be modified
and then in the intermediary
intermediate it's bounded rationality so
not that's it's kind of like a
compromise between what you think is
possible and
magical realism
then the action phase also can be uh run
um a ground by inept
uh
focusing on basically poor
outcomes like if you're
aiming for five degrees off of shooting
a free throw then you're gonna miss the
free throws
and then that also your attention
could be affected by poor signal to
noise ratio like if you couldn't see
where the hoop was
and just interesting how like it's being
really methodically broken down the
sources of where the error can come from
and then also
um in table three there's a nice
distinction
and it relates to that notion that
active inference would be uh potentially
very effective for repetitive processes
but potentially not as effective for
one-of-a-kind processes
and so the repetitive processes are like
mass production and then the
one-of-a-kind processes are like the
project production so right off the bat
it's kind of like well how individual
does a project need to be
before it's not uh
best modeled by active inference
and then it just talks about how markup
like it's generative models prediction
error and variational free energy play
out in both of these
two areas
so that would definitely be something
for people to like read through the
table and then
mention it and give a specific example
or question to the author because this
is like super informative and a cool
combinatoric way to look at how ideas
are related so yeah dean and then blue
so when i'm looking at this and i don't
know if this is helpful or if this just
makes it even more turbid but
if if one hand of this is the ability to
frame something so that we know what's
in
what we're looking at versus what we're
not looking at and if the other hand is
how we match
essentially if you go back to
table two and this table three and and
the figure the matching is what's super
ordinate and what's subordinate what's
inside of what
those are the two hands that still
doesn't tell us what is going on in
between which i think is the fit piece
which from uh
from a thinking standpoint is am i
fitting now
hand in glove meaning
is is my is my glove size size large
or is it glove in hand does that does
the glove i need
serve the purpose because i'm skiing or
because i'm i'm
i'm foraging or i'm or i'm water skiing
right so
between
framing
and
and matching
is this fit question there all three of
them are different things the fit is in
between these other two things and even
if we
make a great table
and even if we make sure that we got the
right headings and right definitions
underneath it still doesn't talk about
is it
glove in hand or hand in glove and i
think for people who want to actually
use active inference
they want to be able to not get stuck
conflating
fit with frame
or
complaining fit with match they want to
put those two parameters the the frame
and the match on the outside and then
see what happens in the middle based on
what those parameters are i think that's
the struggle for most people
trying to gain entree into well
how does this active inference thing
actually work
it works different all the time that's
the point of the markov blanket it's the
potential
to be able to invert
at will that i think
laying it out this way helps it gets you
like 90 of the way there but it doesn't
really tell you what you could do with
it as opposed to
what just happened
very interesting dean
blue
so
like just kind of this piggy backs right
off of what what dean was saying like
the markov blanket and even here in the
first um
the line of this table
um
you know the markup blankets are hard
when they're shifting right and this is
something that we've talked about in
other um live streams in other contexts
like shifting overlapping my markup
blanket interacting with your marco
blanket i think that um you know the
underlying mathematics to support those
kinds of
um arguments are kind of missing still
or or not not missing but still being
worked out is probably more correct
um but but i do think that markov
blankets do change i mean even if i just
think about like my brain as you know
markov blanket like cells die cells are
born and i know that that's very
controversial in the neuroscience field
but but cells are actually born
so so i mean there's there's constantly
this this turnover of who belongs inside
the markov blanket and any kind of you
know organizational structure has that
shift it's not like the boundary of the
markov blanket it has to be has to
retain some kind of flexibility and and
so that um you know is is seen here in
this in this um
first line um and also who's generative
model is it
like so this is kind of another
something that that i was like
so the quality management solution or or
the qms right quality
i maybe got the abbreviation wrong but
um
that that is the gen that is the
generative model but like who does it
belong to is that does it belong to the
process does it belong to and this is
maybe my like a deficiency in
my understanding of
industrial engineering because i'm just
not familiar with the jargon but like is
it the process that gets the quality
management solution or is it the
organization that has the quality
management or is it like some kind of
sub unit is it a team so i'm just kind
of unsure about they talk about this is
the generative model but like whose
model is it and like so depending on on
how that's answered and we'll have the
author on so we can ask them but
depending on how that's answered
you know the these one-of-a-kind
processes as i said earlier can maybe
you be used to update the generative
model in a very um explorative kind of
way
nice
so here's just for a few
uh implications and bigger questions
so here's just a quote markov blankets
are not features of real world systems
rather they are an intuitive post-hoc
ascriptions
rather they are intuitive post-hoc
scriptions made in order to model
real-world systems
hence any description of a markov
blanket is subjective and can be changed
over time as the modeler's focus changes
and or as real-world systems change in
the opinion of the modeler
thus as summarized by phrases such as
the map is not the territory markov
blankets
and then also it this is a funny line
it has been already been argued in
relation to markov blankets and other
important constructs in active inference
theory that the math is not the
territory
wherever you heard that one before but
this is like kind of the ultimate
instrumental
take it's it's making a clean
distinction between map and territory
between the the
utility driven use of active inference
and claims about what the system really
is
and then um
uh this just the last line but it's an
interesting quote but i'll just read the
last line is um
move to the slides
hence the description of markov blankets
could be a recurring challenge
throughout project production which may
only be resolved by reference to
decisions made in courts of law long
after the project is completed
just maybe think about i don't know
maybe like the bay bridge being built in
the bay area in california and like you
know years later and it happened
differently and i'm sure some companies
were bought and sold and
all the morphing of the organization and
the physical modification of the project
and the personnel changing over
all of that which is sort of this on one
hand it's an n equals one unique enacted
situation but then on the other hand
there's principles for engineering it
well and uh
sometimes the process is itself
wondering about how it's organized and
then sometimes you can't even know until
it's after it's done so that's just kind
of cool and funny
um
another quote
this is sort of taking a
take on philosophy from the engineering
perspective
exactly how beliefs are updated in
embodied cognition is a topic of ongoing
research which involves specialist
mathematics to describe relationships
between prior probabilities and
posterior probabilities
by contrast updating beliefs through
active inference in industrial
engineering and quality management
involves applying well-established
practical methods
in particular planning what should
happen by active inference involves
developing processes through applying
industrial engineering techniques
so it's sort of like we know what our
policy affordances and um
uh mechanism of updating our affordances
are that's our discipline
and so
more broader question is what are the
implications for generalized frameworks
like
embody cognition or active inference
what
are the implications when they interface
with disciplinary or project specific
like one-time
work
and then how does active inference uh
gets simplified in the context of
industrial engineering and how does work
in the disciplines become linked in a
bi-directional conversation to the
broader body of knowledge
just
general questions any thoughts or okay
dean yeah go for it
dean you're muted yeah i can't hear you
um
whether we're talking about the bay
bridge as
do we have the proper glove in hand
or whether we're talking about
instrumentalism do i actually have a
precise
fit of glove for my hand yeah i think i
think what what we have to be
aware of is that
both of those questions come up
post hoc
i tried on the glove and it worked or
uh maybe the design of the bay bridge
should have been different given the
the contextual circumstances
well i'm all i'm
curious about is
so before the bay bridge is built before
i i fit
one of two questions into that gloved
hand relationship am i aware of how
that can be seen post talk or ad hoc and
am i am i
am i
conscious of the fact of where i'm
taking this active inference model and
as blue pointed out earlier whose is it
and now just as importantly when
is it
when is that when is that question being
asked in the context of what the product
is because if we're going to talk about
social organizations as the product
active inference allows us to look on
both sides of that so
if as long as we're including the win in
terms of discovering fit
i think i think we're actually using
active inference
in terms of what its potential is that's
all
nice comments little philosophy like we
i'm not not not like we need that but
i'm just throwing it in there yeah
that's cool
so then here's another quote
um
in terms of the explore exploit dynamic
project production involves much more
exploration than exploitation hence more
wayfinding than navigation is involved
in particular wayfinding involves the
ability to create novel routes which are
based
on understanding a wider frame of
reference than navigating along a preset
route
wayfinding involves creating novel
routes through changing situations by
making non-conscious reference to
subjective prior knowledge and conscious
subjective reference to current
situations and semantic information
that's pretty dense but pretty
fascinating because it does point at
this kind of like repetitive
then you can just write out the
directions and follow them in a little
bit more of a rule following way
um
and then the extreme case being like a
train like the caltrain just went from
san francisco to san jose just went and
it was like it had you know the
affordance to speed up or slow down but
then
when there's the bushwhacking um or the
wayfinding here
then there's almost like novelty of path
and then there's higher novelties like
introducing a new tool or climbing to
the top of a tree to see further but
there's just this path finding novelty
that is uh really important for you know
all kinds of these applications so it
just
raises the question that'll be cool to
discuss
about like
how does active inference
uh juxtapose or interface with sense
making and wayfinding
explore exploit the pragmatic epistemic
distinction
and then the way that the models are fit
with accuracy minus complexity just how
does that
come together and active
any thoughts or good
yep dean
yeah because because weight finding is
my
is my niche i was just so happy that he
pulled these two
reference like if you haven't read 90
like work of 95 and 96 here i strongly
recommend it because he's pulled out two
fantastic references
in terms of uh
things you could look at in terms of
what that exploration piece actually is
that they're both fantastic especially
the 95
yeah i've read both of them and they're
both they're both excellent examples
within the context of what he's trying
to talk about in terms of implications i
just wanted to do a clap for that one
because i thought
glad glad he brought the wayfinding
piece into this cool yeah the 95 is
finding the way a critical discussion of
anthropological theories of human
spatial orientation with reference to
reindeer herders of north eastern europe
and western siberia 2009
and then the second article is humans
used predictive gay strategies to target
waypoints for steering 2019. so it's
kind of interesting because um
and especially having adapted a visual
foraging model
to a stigma g pheromone deposition model
in the active inference paper
it has
drawn out this contrast between two
extremes of foraging
um both which can have a pragmatic and
an epistemic component there's like skin
in the game
ant body on the ground where you're
physically moving you're hurting and you
have to go somewhere to find out how it
is there versus visual foraging or
visual scanning is uh sort of like you
have the cost of movement of course but
it's not like um where your eye is is
directly paying the cost um in most
cases so it's kind of cool to see that
the wayfinding and the sense making
comes into play on these two extremes
with a niche modifying body on the
ground as well as with a scanning
approach
okay um another quote
won't read the whole thing but basically
we can imagine after hearing all this
that the prediction error is something
that you want to minimize for effective
business operation so a large prediction
error could lead to the company
dissipating for example through its
internal resources being scattered into
an external state by being taken into
the possession of its unplayed paid
suppliers so that's um
marcotte blanket dissolution via
court-mediated bankruptcy proceeding
alternatively the company could be
acquired and merged into one of its
large unpaid suppliers that seeks to
move up the value chain from tier one to
oem manufacturer
in the case of acquisition and merger
the description of markov blankets would
need to be changed in legal documents
so that just totally uh set off my scott
david alarm
and
maybe think about um the ways that the
markov blankets um can be designed the
the
managing synthetic externalities
um
seeing law as a niche modification and
as a technology in and of itself but
also one that uh can
facilitate other technologies coming
into existence or being hindered as we
see all the time
and then
he uses the acronym bolts
business operational legal technical
social
and then the bigger question is like how
can we see active inference serve in a
de-risking or recovery capacity
and then how can we
reframe existing or emerging practices
for resilience in terms of active
inference so this is like a 1980 style
merger and acquisition
framed in the markham blanket framework
but
what does the d5
active inference model look like what
does the smart contract active inference
model look like these will be like
really interesting questions and how
they're going to intersect with formal
laws as well as the code is law
any comments
okay and then i think the last point was
just
in the further directions of the paper
further refinement of active inference
constructs is needed to enable wide
application to social organization
employing human and artificial
intelligence
apropos the practical examples in the
paper can provide starting points for
research into the challenges of
ascribing markov blankets defining
generative models handling pragmatics
and modeling variational free energy in
real world social organization and
that's an idea that we touched on in our
2020 paper active inference and behavior
engineering for teams which is that in
the case of remote teams
then
the entire structure can be observed
through the sensory data that's sent to
a user and then the actions that are
received for example on either side of
an interface or either side of a
blockchain wallet so for remote teams
because they're defined digitally we
have access to the entire state space so
to speak of sensory and active states
whereas for trying to do the um active
inference model of people in a physical
boardroom that's always going to be
complicated even if you have a really
effective way to get body position out
of the cameras in the room for example
so just kind of cool to think about
uh industrial design or engineering
all these different
ideas we talked about
in terms of online as well as physical
engineering so not just like cars and
stuff
those are hardware and software as well
so we kind of just closed by saying um
what
people can give their last thoughts blue
and dean just what would a good
understanding enable what are some good
unique predictions or implications or
areas that this
line of research might be addressing
what are the next steps for this kind of
research the goals of the research and
then also just what you're curious about
asking the author tomorrow and in the
following week
yeah i think i've laid out some
questions um today that i hope i don't
forget for tomorrow but um
i definitely think that uh
active inference in
systems and organizations and social
structures is
definitely important um along with like
the validation of your model through
other models like through the models of
other people and through like this this
confirmation bias like oh my model must
be good because you have a model that's
like my model so so i think that this
this existence um
it can help to really set boundaries and
definitions on
on um
how we really form social structures not
just businesses and and i mean in
business there's kind of a hierarchical
component and um but i mean also like
society as a whole we form these social
structures and how does this social
morphogenesis really take place so i
think really the author puts out a good
um you know way of of kind of delving
into social morphogenesis uh even
through like quality quality management
and industrial engineering but it's it's
definitely first steps
any final comments
well i'm really looking forward to
talking to the author because
i think at the end of the day rather
than
um
what's the word here rather than
exploring
why
why these these mappings have been put
together in this paper i i'm kind of
curious now about trying to figure out
so when did
when did these parallels sort of form in
his mind and get to a place where he
could take a lot of this background
information because he's i mean he's
really
cleverly and and thoroughly sourced here
when did he sort of put these two things
together as a reflection of one another
and where does he see that going forward
totally agreed it's a single author
paper that
reflects a really deep understanding and
probably a lot of experience presenting
and thinking about this and maybe even
applying it so those are all super
interesting areas to find out about
all right well blue dean thanks that was
epic thanks for all the help on the
slides and on the stream
so that was great we'll uh talk to
everybody in the dot 1.2 or later so bye
thanks dan